gentlemen congratulations this is just
so incredible i i know that you both
worked on the screenplay together where
did the idea for the story come from i
mean it came i guess just from our own
experience you know we developed a close
friendship and we
realized actually the one character i
never get to play is someone like myself
yeah you know i play in different
accents different time zones planets uh
you know and and similarly with bassam
you know it's very rare that you know
you're asked to direct something that's
specifically about our experience and we
realize that actually
that could be kind of fresh and kind of
bold and if we did something really
honest maybe not everyone could relate
to the day-to-day but everyone would
relate to the honesty and that's
certainly what we've been seeing with
people's reactions
and what about for you bassan
yeah i think the reason that we did a
trip together to see if we'd uh if we
could actually like make this work and
we were in pakistan and everywhere i saw
rizz he would always have a notebook
with him and he would write things so
then i looked at his notebook and i
realized he writes in verse and every he
processes the world through verse and
lyrics
and i always knew he was a rapper but
then at that moment i was like this
guy's actually a writer that just
happens to also be a very successful
actor so to me it was like this is what
we need to use as our fuel and and at
that moment i knew that we needed to
anchor this in the story of an artist
and try to use verse to help build the
arc of the story and i think to then see
riz unleashed with his own words whether
it was from the raps that he was writing
for his album his first self-titled
album which is incredible the long
goodbye or uh it was the stuff that we
were coming up on the day but just to
see him bring that energy to life and
it's quite visceral and just exciting
and aggressive at the same time
vulnerable was just really fun and that
was really what i wanted to do it was
more of an exercise of what it would
look like to work with a friend on a
project like this
that's amazing i mean how important is
it to you for both of you really to
showcase your own upbringing and culture
on on the big screen
i mean i guess if you're going to tell a
personal story you're going to show you
know
um
you know the place that you're from and
and and and really there's so much of
the film is about that push and pull
between you and where you're from you're
on the one hand it might inspire you to
do what you do on the other hand it
might hold you back to do what you want
to do
um
you know you're looking for the embrace
of that place but you don't want it to
embrace you so hard that you can't get
away and that tug of war between you and
where you're from you know that idea
really a family you can't live with them
you can't live without them
that's really what the film is about and
and and so i think it's inevitable that
you're going to kind of show your
upbringing your culture your family when
you're telling a personal story about
home and about family
yeah yeah how about you
yeah i think i think i really like what
said because i think when when we were
doing this it was always just
always asking the question of like but
what is the honest like what what where
is the honesty in this what's the truth
in this i think great actors are
gatekeepers of truth so as we go through
page by page it was always that question
it was never a question of how are we
representing our community what does it
look like because i think at any moment
when you start worrying about the
audience you've already shot yourself in
the foot so i think so much just making
sure that we are feeling that that it's
that it's that it's coming from an
honesty that we can connect with the
truth that we can connect with then
perhaps i should be okay with it as well
yeah absolutely
you were both friends before this
incredible project but
you've been cheering on rizz as he
becomes a superstar and an oscar
nominated actor what is this what is
this like to watch
oh man it's like it's it's really just
so amazing because when i first met riz
he was just doing the night of on hbo
and it was just he was shooting it and i
knew he just he just had it and i was
like i just can't wait for the world to
know who he is so so to so even be there
while he was also working in sound of
metal and doing those other stuff it's
like he is such a hard worker and he's
been doing it for a long ass time so i
think it's finally his he's getting i
think you know it's it's a little bit
like finally right like damn right
people are seeing it so i mean it's just
it's we're both getting so old now we're
both transitioning into proud ankles
we're like proud he's like oh yes
my son and i feel the same way about him
i'm like uncle rizwan going up assam
he's dead he's made this you know now
he's directing blade he's he's doing the
thing i remember i remember
this is the moment we've become uncles
yeah but i like it but what is that sort
of i don't know having someone who can
really understand your journey
and celebrate your wins and be there for
the tough times what does that mean in
an industry like this
i'll i'll say one thing it's really
scary for me raise i'll be really honest
because like there's something about
working with with your friends where
it's like you know we always have to say
like yeah we'll one day work together
and you know we were doing our own
things but when you work with someone
that
is very very similar to you that knows
your culture that knows all the
specifics of it you can't hide anymore
right like i couldn't outside i couldn't
hide anymore like i just had to be more
honest you know what i mean like where
it's like well and well i i have to do
this prayer thing or this horrible well
i have this one it's like no he gets it
he knows it he knows it backwards and
forwards and all around it so that's
scary like that's really scary where i
couldn't hide behind it but you know
within the with it i mean um
within the kind of like the the industry
and stuff it's obviously really
meaningful to have people around you
that can relate to experience and that's
for a couple of reasons one is you've
got people you trust you can turn to
you've got collaborators you can vibrate
with a shorthand but also i think just
the more people you have around you that
share similar experience the more you
believe in the validity of that
experience the more you think yeah oh
you know what
maybe maybe this is a story worth
telling actually maybe this is a story
that people want to hear
if you're in a room full of people that
are like dude i cannot relate to that at
all
then suddenly you're less likely to tell
that story so i think it's really
emboldening on many levels
well enjoy both of you thank you so much
for your honesty and for this beautiful
piece of work we appreciate it thank you
so much
you